our friends over in Salt Lake City had a
recent experience the cost of a college
education is nearly doubled over the
past decade so one hard-working student
decided to respond with a unique protest
by paying his tuition in $1 bills I
can't pronounce the gentleman's name
McCall I guess McCall I'm going to call
him already goes to class 10 hours a day
during the week really 10 hours a day
during the week goes to class that would
be more than a full load
I've got college students that have had
them for years and I don't know of
anybody who went to class 10 hours a day
during the week but I'll let that stand
for a minute Andy works 16-hour shifts
at the local Home Depot during the
weekend good for him when it came time
to pay for school he and hundreds of
other students waited in line and he did
say and he carted in the thousands of $1
bills to pay for his tuition in a metal
carrying case everyone was peering over
my shoulder when I opened the chest he
chest he told the student paper McCullen
says he wasn't trying to make life
difficult for anyone working in the
university of billing department rather
he wanted to make the point make a point
about the ever increasing price of a
college education when you spend cash
you feel every dollar that you hand over
to someone else you feel you're losing
that if you just swipe your card it
could be 10,000 or 100,000 and you don't
really feel it when you actually slide
over a huge pile of cash you feel like
you've spent something
well that's true that's why we've told
people for years to pay for things in
cash it changes your world I think it's
awesome that he decided to do something
different and because he was feeling the
weight of the tuition I disagree with a
couple things in the article but um but
overall I mean he's worked his butt off
he paid cash for his tuition that's
awesome he felt the weight of it and
felt the value of what he was investing
in for the education I don't think he
lost the money I think when he slid it
across he invested the money into him
of Education is a good investment in
most cases assuming you're studying
something that's actually has a
marketplace application I'm glad that he
felt that I'm glad he's working so hard
to get through and what a neat idea I
mean he's thinking differently and you
know $1 bills
makes the point to yourself that it's
expensive it also makes the point to the
university that this is expensive and it
reminds them that this is real money
these aren't just digits and I think
it's a good thing for universities to
remember this is real money when they
are taking the in vet when they're
taking the money that a student is
investing into themselves for an
education which implies they should give
value for that money a great education
and they should guide them in taking
course doing coursework that makes sense
and that is applicable that's it that's
good for the education institution the
university to feel the weight of that
it's good for McCall to feel the weight
of that I'm not sure I'm going along
with the protest part of this because if
you want to protest something the way
you protest it is you don't do it you
know if you want to protest what someone
charges for something the way you
protest that is you don't buy it so I'm
not sure this was actually a protest and
it's like somehow you have the right to
tell them what they're going to charge
but if you say I don't like what you
charge for that the best way to say I
don't like what you charge for that
other than talk about it is to not give
them your money that will adjust their
world after a while and it's part of the
reason education education cost has gone
through the roof is because of the
Student Loan debacle students borrow
money without even thinking that it's
real money give it to universities that
don't even act like it's real money and
the money is so accessible and there's
so much of it because you and I the
taxpayers guarantee it that there's a -
there's so many dollars chasing the
education world around that the
educational world gets the idea they can
charge anything and so these huge
tuition increases happen we just tell
you there's a simple thing and
genomics called a supply demand curve
when there is less demand than there is
supply there is pressure downward on
pricing when there's a shortage of
something more demand than there is
supply the pressure is upward on pricing
and so that's what's happening here we
have more demand because of easy student
loans then we have supply and so
university tuition continues to
skyrocket but if you were to back down
the demand and fewer people were chasing
those universities around begging them
to get to go there then there's a
downward pressure yes there's an actual
cost associated with supplying the
education and so forth but these things
they tend to adjust themselves when
there's no customers and so that's part
of the equation so I'm not really up for
a protest
not while you're handing people your
money but this is a great cool thing
young men felt the weight of the cost of
his education the investment of his
education the university felt the weight
of it and it made a great story and we
got to talk about it so something to
think about by the way when you pay cash
for things it activates the pain centers
in your brain he's right about that
several studies indicating that you feel
it when you pay cash if you lay a couple
of $100 bills on the counter to buy
something you know you bought something
you feel it when you just swipe the
plastic you don't feel it he's exactly
right about that very insightful young
man very cool stuff
you